camille tu as une séquence qui est
arrivé il ya deux ans c'était les frères
me rappelle comment on s'en était par
l'élite et on semble exactement et les
normes pense quoi ton frère joue dur ils
en pensent quoi ton frère et je déteste
et petit train d'ailleurs quoi sert la
dîme et font changer crise et c'est pas
possible c'est pourri c'est vrai et je
les gardais way est atteint il ya peu de
gens qui disent ils en pensent quoi
tandis que ce hammam lif et après j'ai
tellement aimé tic à chaque émission peu
des camille je voulais le décliner
exactions il empochera camille gens
pensent quoi les parodies cette fois je
vous laisse des cultes et camille et
c'est vrai qu'ils en pensent quoi ton
frère on a on a fait une compil des
meilleurs c'est et je vous jure
quand je les fais georges les quand on
en a parlé camille jamais j'aurais cru
que ça allait être aussi drôle et tu la
fais vraiment mieux que ce que c'est
vraiment et les gens ils sont super
gentils et vous savez il faut faire
signer les gens une fois qu'on a
autorisé sans avoir l'autorisation de
passer je vous jure quand on en a triché
0 en 3 ou 3 en deux ans trois ans
maintenant
il ya peut-être trois personnes qui ont
refusé de signer après le piège comme
quoi c'est bon esprit et où va ce qu'ils
savent pas du tout les gens 0 perd trois
personnes maximum en deux ans on sourit
on les a pas c'est quand même bien sont
ils de cette partie
[Musique]
auger un scooter et je les prends quand
le scooter cheval prendre quand je peux
pas prendre le vélo ça dépend d'une
méthode ça devait dépend du temps et ccc
en heures de pointe c'est un peu
compliqué il ya toujours du monde et on
arrive transférant au boulot à part ça
c'est pas mal et votre elle en pense
quoi
j'ai pas de frère mais [ __ ] j'allais
oublié celui-là
les équipes des jo de pékin express
alors on est sur tout ce qui est bon qu
on cherche rotenberg là normalement on a
un aventure avec le rodobe enfin c'est
quand même chaud quoi je pensais que tu
avais laissé je pensais que j'avais
réussi à me débarrasser de mes potes
transports en commun tu me fais ma
rendant tout depuis deux semaines gaza
fait deux semaines que je bouffe du ri
pak huige et j'en peux plus
rendez-vous au totem au total huit
auteurs qu'est ce que vous pensez des
transports en commun sont à l'arrêt
transports en commun parisiens sont on
va dire bien parce qu'on peut on peut
voir paris mais dans l'ensemble la somme
j'ai rien à dire et c'est pas mal et
l'auxois l'on pense quoi la star c'est
l'enfance
[Rires]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
c'est les blondes mais c'est l'élan de
carpentras ron de guerre entre
connaissez peut-être on en a fait des
ravages au macumba
on a des fausses couches et des vraies
envies qu'est ce que vous pensez des
transports en commun parisiens a été
meilleur suivi paris 85 ans j'ai pris le
métro les juifs de la faune à pied mais
les transports il ya une et votre frère
il en pense quoi
j'ai parfois bien
comment vas tu es toi sortait de prison
l'a alors profitez-en vous n'allez pas
tarder à y retourner
je pense qu'on a me choix entre les
transports à la cub heures
taxis g7 etc et il met trop je pense que
le choix est large
d autres en pensent quoi j'ai pas de
faire première nouvelle
ferroukhi le pivot de brice mais on s'en
sort ça va
[Applaudissements]